[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show and i
am your host paul and in this video
we're going to be breaking down
everything we know about the upcoming
what if episodes there's a lot of
mystery surrounding the series and
though everything seems completely
disconnected i do believe it's all
connected now we're building to an
all-out multiversal wall with all the
avengers coming together for the final
episode this will be to stop one of the
greatest threats that the marvel
universe has ever seen since scarlett
johansson decided to sue disney see you
in court now the first thing i want to
talk about is the apparent episode list
and the concepts behind them i was lucky
enough to get early access to the first
three so i can confirm that at least
part of this lineup is correct and going
off what we've seen in the trailer these
do seem like the concepts that we'll be
getting now i was put under embargo for
the first three and told not to really
spoil anything but the show owners did
say what those episodes were so i think
i can at least talk about that now the
second episode is what if t'challa was
star-lord and it sees what would have
happened had chadwick boseman's
character been picked up instead of
peter quill it's a really emotional
episode and by far my favorite out of
the first three i think with the first
episode that many people complained that
it was pretty much just the first
adventure with a peggy caught a skin on
whilst i enjoyed it i also think that's
a fair assessment to make but outside of
the first five minutes episode two goes
off into a completely different
direction and a lot of the characters
from the guardians franchise are changed
massively there's a big villain who is
now one of the good guys and it's really
really well made episode 3 takes place
during the week of iron man 2 the
incredible hulk and also thor in the mcu
timeline these all take place a couple
of days apart and we see as black widow
investigates the mystery behind who's
trying to stop the avengers from being
formed it's a great little detective
story that again divulges heavily from
what happened in the movies before
whilst also paying homage to them now
like i said i don't know if these other
episodes are definitely these concepts
but this list is pretty widespread now
and it does line up with the trailers
this comes from mcu source and it says
that the fourth episode will feature the
supreme doctor strange in the trailers
we watched as steven has met a darker
version of himself within the multiverse
and this makes a lot of sense to have it
as episode 4 as this tends to be the
point in a series where writers normally
start to explain things that's not just
me being rich richards either and if you
look at shows like westworld watchmen
one division and more writers typically
tend to tease what's going on for the
first three to get people hooked and
then they start explaining things
roughly around the fourth ac bradley aka
the screenwriter for what if has been
giving a lot of interviews recently to
promote the show and she talked about
that episode listing it as a standout
when discussing the series she said
i have a few favorites the doctor
strange episode was a very special one
to me for writing and going into it i
was quite scared because it features
some very heavy themes i don't think
that it's a spoiler to say that it deals
with flaws and tragedy once i sat down
and started working on it it was
actually a very rewarding experience
because we got to play around with why
does loss hurt so much and because it
all comes down to love only the things
we love can hurt us this is the most
human episode of the lot but it also has
some beautiful imagery some amazing
action and hopefully a few good twists
because of this i think that christine
palmer might have died on this earth and
then we'll be seeing a version of
strange that is ripped up in the
multiverse in order to find a variant of
her we've seen that it is possible to
bring characters back like gamora and
therefore i think that strange will be
attempting to do this with her brian
andrews director for the show also
brought up the entry and said this when
going over it the doctor strange episode
is a tour de force it ends in a
particular way you'll know it when you
see it when you actually see it they're
gonna be like i can't believe they did
that [ __ ] now interestingly we've seen
in the trailers that captain carter
meets strange at some point and thus we
can take it that these episodes aren't
standalone and that they will be
building towards something bigger i
actually think that the episode will end
with strange coming across captain
carter and that he'll basically be the
nick fury of the multiverse going around
and rounding up the heroes it is rumored
that captain carter is going to be in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and there are also reports that
schumer gorath is going to be one of the
villains in that movie if we were right
in our breakdown then the big tentacle
monster that appeared at the end of
episode 1 might be the same as that and
we could see it in live action very very
soon there could also potentially be a
multiversal war which we'll talk about
later on in the video i think that this
is an important detail to bear in mind
now if you love the video phase 3000
then i'd massively appreciate the thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe as we
do breakdowns like this each and every
day you're some of the [ __ ] i know you
haven't subscribed yet so bloody click
it it turns red it looks really good now
episode five is gonna be party thought
which i'm guessing is what would happen
if thor didn't go to juttenheim and
fight the frost giants what do you mean
it doesn't turn red and i've ruined the
video
scr saw that moving on now if if he
didn't go to johanheim to fight the
frost giants then this would mean that
he wouldn't be cast out and then you
wouldn't have to earn his place in the
intro for what if we could actually
catch a beardless store and this could
also be the one that we saw in the
trailer potentially he's not worthy and
he's just been living the life of riley
having a great time and not having to
deal with any of the problems on mid god
now episode 6 is apparently the tony and
killmonger one in the trailer we saw
that there was a scene in which we
opened with the beginning of iron man
but instead of the missile blowing him
back he was saved by killmonger i got a
lot of bloody flack for this a lot of
bloody flak i tell you but in my episode
one breakdown i did say that in the
titles it looked like killmonger was the
one hammering away on the iron man suit
with an arc reactor in his chest people
were savage and it's been living in my
head rent-free like peter parker but i'm
still pretty sure it's him and that this
comes from this episode because the
missile doesn't explode and blows
shrapnel into his chest he'll never need
to have the arc reactor placed into it
and therefore it does make sense that he
would invent it for killmonger as at
this point he's still a weapon stealer
obviously if you disagree then let me
know in the comments as i know people
have a lot to say on whether this is
killmonger or not but personally i'm
sticking by it and if it doesn't come
true i'm just gonna ignore it like i do
every time i get a fan theory wrong now
next is marvel zombies based on the
long-running comic series from well
marvel from the toy leaks we know that
peter parker will actually be a zombie
hunter in this universe and that he'll
have doctor strange's cape i'm guessing
that means that this dock is dead in
that universe and it could even explain
why the sorcerer's supreme version is
traveling from dimension to dimension
and rounding of the heroes i think this
is the one in which you will see
ant-man's head in a jar i'm guessing
this is a nod to reanimate in which
something similar happened and the
undead being around would explain how
he's still alive after this episode a is
apparently gamora versus tony and
judging by the posters and figures this
will probably be the one in which he
wears the thanos armor now again i can't
spell too much of episode 2 but it could
potentially tie in with this universe
and once you see the entry it'll make a
lot more sense as to why gamora might
have taken up her father's quote-unquote
destiny lastly is apparently the ultron
episode which i think is going to be
where the multiversal war stems from by
the looks of it ultron has completely
overrun one timeline and the heroes are
having to be pulled together in order to
fight against this we get an avengers
assemble as shot in the trailers in
which several of the characters from
multiple worlds team up and this
includes what i believe is killmonger's
black panther thanos gamora t'challa
star-lord and party thor in the second
trailer we can see thor fighting against
several ultron bots in las vegas so that
just makes a lot of sense to me now i
did before yeah i did say in avengers
assemble-esque shot because in england
the movie is actually called avengers
assemble and not the avengers because
there was a tv show called the avengers
and also a movie about that which they
just didn't want to get confused over
bit of trivia there for you now i'm
guessing that captain carter will also
be in the lineup too as well as
spider-man and doctor strange in the
trailer we can see that there's a
version of black widow throwing a shield
i'm pretty sure that this will be from a
certain upcoming episode but i can't say
which because of spoilers now i think
that ultron's uprising will have
destroyed an entire timeline and from
here the machine will be looking to
decimate all realities and thus strange
will have to pull together the heroes to
help stop him once and for all you might
have seen that after the release of
episode 1 that marvel did a tie-in
promotion with hyundai in which they
showed aspects of this ultron war as
well as the heroes from the show
fighting off against this legion i think
it just makes a lot of sense that this
is the direction they're going in and
the heroes might even lose which could
set up events in the second season we
know that captain carter is returning
for that and i think it would be great
to have the heroes be beaten at the end
of episode 9 to tease ultron tearing
across time and space in order to
conquer all in season 2 i'd absolutely
love it if they did what if what if
episode one had steve get the super
soldier serum instead of peggy and it
would just be crazy to see this guy in
the mcu i've even mocked up mocked up a
quick fan poster so we can kind of get a
rough idea and i think that's the
direction that they should go in season
two thank you now that pretty much sums
up everything and obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the series they
call me re-captain america because i'll
be bringing you big recaps and
breakdowns on the show every single week
also don't forget to drive hyundai if
you watch the show you have to put 30
grand down right now on a hyundai to
really just to really enjoy it for what
it is now if you don't have that money
good news for you we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three mc box sets on the 30th of august
they're not hyundai's but yeah they're
still pretty good and all you have to do
to be with the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the series
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of captain america the
first avenger in which we've gone
through the whole movie and pointed out
every easter egg we could find as well
as how it ties to what if if not then
thank you for sitting through the video
you've been the best i've been paul i
hope you've enjoyed it take care peace
you